with uh stories that we have cosby
you guys saw cosby as it there's two
stories that's going on everywhere one
is cosby one is spears
you know britney spears so what do you
think about what happened with cosby
here i'll jump out on cosby is like i
wrote in vtpost.com i said raise your
hand if you saw this one coming
i thought he was going to die in prison
we all did right i mean it was a parade
he was did you see it coming god no
nobody held them that's why i said if
you actually saw this coming raise your
hand because nobody did
he was the first of the celebrities to
go down in the hashtag metoo movement
yeah he was numero uno and they got him
and it was a
it was a just a progression i mean the
guy is a great a
creep i mean you cannot dispute that um
but you know what if you like this
country you should be very happy that he
was released yesterday because this
all falls on that d.a that charged him
when they promised him he won it
okay and when you see what's going on
with trump where they're spending
millions and millions of dollars and
just doing anything they can to
fabricate something and find something
they promised him they wouldn't charge
him
he then incriminated himself in a
deposition in the civil suit
and then they came back used that
information and charged him so
technically
he should be let go this is a great
country it proves it right there i don't
like cosby but i like the fact he's out
because she's like on that conviction
on that on that on that conviction yeah
the fact that that you know
they're considering this like double
jeopardy that he's not gonna get uh he's
not gonna go to trial for any of the
other
uh allegations and accusations is a
little bit rough and it really goes back
to
you know one it kind of is the official
end of me too like you said it's kind of
the
the the book end on me too um i think
you know once the democratic party was
okay with uh
you know president biden bowling balling
uh his his interns that you know
they didn't they didn't say anything
about that after years of of trump
grabbing by the
you know you know and then biden is
accused of actually literally doing that
and then that gets swept under the wrong
that was the unofficial
end of me too they lost any foot to
stand on this is the end of it
you know it's i think me too in
retrospect
uh was a very important thing i really
do i think that metoo
had its place i think that especially
with harvey weinstein especially
with la i i think anybody who looks back
at old school television look at richard
dawson
on family feud on live television just
absolutely like
aggressively just stealing people's
mouths on tv like
okay we needed to pull back on on you
know the people that were abusing power
absolutely needed it but then it it
became just like everything else it
became politicized and it became
like a tool for people to use so is this
a good thing with cosby
i think overall it's a good i think
anything that exposes
what's wrong with our society in this
moment of pain and change is good i keep
saying it
that this we're entering an era of
authenticity
and you have to be honest and you have
to be truthful everybody's going to find
out everything eventually
and you're talking about that d.a like
that d.a needs to be prosecuted
that d.a needs to answer questions like
hey as long as you help me get this
other conviction i won't prosecute your
27 rape allegations look i don't want to
put
a famous black man in jail so scratch my
back
and i'll scratch yours that's not
justice and
and you know what unfortunately that is
justice in america and uh we sat down
with
like we can't really talk about
unfortunately but we sat down with
somebody very very powerful for an
interview
last week and my big takeaway from that
interview pat asked some incredibly
poignant questions
there's like no laws in this country
everything is completely
under interpretation at all times it
it's a scary thought
it all depends on what the prosecutor is
under interpretation right now the
history of the country
it's what the prosecutor wants to go
after and that's it the prosecution the
prosecutors and the courts
are the most powerful things in this
world you see the videos too
of they're not charging anybody for
thefts under thought over
under a thousand dollars in california
the 27 walgreens in the san francisco
bay area had to be shut down
because of all the crime people walk in
there take what they want and leave
and then if you get these soros
appointed da's you're in real trouble if
you live in a city like that
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye